un tercio de las gasolinas en Francia
sigue con problemas de suministro de al
menos un tipo de combustible esto
después de que los sindicatos de
trabajadores del estadounidense eso
Epson y de la francesa total decidirán
prolongarla huelga que están llevando
hace una decena de días por mejoras
salariales Y eso pese aquí anoche una
parte de los sindicatos del
estadounidense concretamente los
sindicatos más hacia la derecha
aceptaran un acuerdo de Propuesta con
los gerentes de la empresa sin embargo
este fue rechazado por los sindicatos
más a la izquierda fuerza Obrera y cgt y
por lo mismo Hace algunos minutos la
primera ministra Elizabeth Von anunció
frente a la asamblea nacional francesa
que va requisicionar es decir obligar a
los trabajadores de los depósitos de eso
Epson a trabajar a levantar la huelga
justamente Este era un debate que tenía
lugar esta mañana tanto los ministros de
economía como el del gobierno habían
advertido de que eso era posible si
hasta huelga ponía en peligro la
continuidad del servicio público
justamente Elizabeth dijo frente a los
diputados que un problema Un desacuerdo
salarial no puede paralizar a todo el
país y ha pedido a los prefectos que
procedan justamente a la requisición de
estos trabajadores los prefectos que
también hoy han anunciado que no se
podrá vender más gasolina en bidones
Pues eso aumenta la escasez de
combustible